he has passed faster than the twinkle of
an eye a tribute to the Dead
as emotions flow freely
a small group of families and survivors
gather to remember
as the years passed their numbers
dwindle but not their problems
on August 14 2017 more than 1 100 people
died as this phase of Sugarloaf Mountain
Broke Free
huge Boulders and tons of debris
cascaded downhill sweeping Away Homes
and people
it was Sierra Leone's worst Single Day
Disaster
I lost his entire family 20 people
I missed the Council of my family that
died on that day I'm so scared of what
may have happened to them
Moses who was only six weeks old at that
time miraculously survived the disaster
but his father did not
five years after the mudslide people are
still building on the slopes of
mountains and hills around Freetown
despite the government ban and experts
say it's only a matter of time before
there is a similar disaster
fight back tears
she survived that terrible day because
she had gone out for Dawn prayer five
years after the mudslide she now faces
homelessness again
I've been asked to leave the
construction site where I live with my
grandchildren I don't know where else to
go or what to do
[Music]
Ethiopia enforcing the law here is weak
some are saying we are did I go about
any provision
for my relocation
if the government wants to take me
out from this place
has they provide me any
uh place
for me for me to go and relocate Sierra
Leone is one of the world's top disaster
prone countries environmentally say
unless official corruption is tackle
such disasters will reoccur and people
will continue to be killed Ahmed Idris
Al Jazeera Pentagon Sierra Leone